foreign
there are a handful of strength
categories that we think really matter
and and just ideas that are important
when you think about strength so
one of them is the importance of
understanding eccentric versus
concentric strength and how both are
very important I actually put something
up on Instagram the other day about this
where I
you know just explained that the
concentric phase is basically the go and
The Eccentric phase is the slow so you
accelerate through concentric Force
which is the force of muscle generates
as it is shortening that moves you
forward the eccentric phase which is
equally important but oft ignored is the
strength or the force that a muscle is
exhibiting as it is lengthening that's
what's decelerating that's what's
slowing you down
Andy Galpin I think recently talked
about
a great metric and I agree this is a
fantastic metric something you know I'll
check mine constantly is how far a broad
jump can you do
so
I want to make sure that I can do a
standing broad jump that's higher than
my height laying down so you know if I'm
five foot ten I want to make sure I'm
jumping at least six feet on a broad
jump and a broad jumps a really
interesting test it's a profoundly
extreme example of concentric and
eccentric strength in the same movement
if you're just standing there and you
want to jump six feet in front of you
that requires an enormous explosion
that's a very high concentric load but
guess what if you want to not break your
nose when you land and destroy your
knees you better be able to decelerate
yourself and slow yourself down that's
an unbelievable eccentric ask
so while that's a very extreme example
consider walking up and down stairs
walking up the stairs is very taxing
concentrically
but where do most people get hurt in
life it's actually walking downstairs
and if you watch
especially as people age the difficulty
they have in slowing themselves down
when they're coming downstairs or taking
a step off a curb this is where people
are falling and breaking their hips it's
far less that they're falling due to
concentric weakness and far more that
they're falling due to Eccentric
weakness
so therefore principle number one in our
strength training is always be doing
both not necessarily in the same
movement not necessarily focusing
equally on a given day but everything we
want to do we want to make sure that we
are hitting the concentric and The
Eccentric phase not just the more
obvious which is the concentric
now does that take the form of Simply
accentuating the lowering in the case of
say trap bar deadlift or something like
that where you have something like two
seconds up four seconds down or does it
take other specific forms there are very
specific exercise that you'll do so for
example like a you know a Nordic rollout
you know Nordic fall you know for a
hamstring exercise where you're you know
what I'm talking about when you're
kneeling on a mat and your feet are held
in position and you sort of allow
yourself to slowly come down that's just
purely eccentric misery requires quite a
bit of starting strength to do well and
and truthfully we wouldn't have people
do that out of the gate you'll do that
with assistance to start because most
people simply don't have the hamstring
strength to do that yes it can be
accomplished greatly by using
slow what we call negatives so focusing
just as much on the negative as the
positive so for example one of my
favorite exercises to do are step UPS
because
one it's a single leg exercise it's a
beautiful hip hinge but we can talk
about it in some detail in a moment
because the hip hinging is another one
of the big principles and
it allows you to do a very nice
isolation of The Eccentric on the step
down
and you really have to be able to
control that if you can't control it
you're using too much resistance
obviously so hip hinging is another big
important principle
and again hip hinging when people think
about that they think that does that
have to be a squat or a deadlift no it
doesn't have to be it can be a hip
Thruster it can be a lunge it can be a
step up I mean I think the Step Up might
be the single most important one for
people to do because it doesn't have any
axial loading could you explain what you
mean by that when you're doing something
like a squat or a deadlift but you
there's there's weight that is basically
pulling your spine down to your hips in
the squat it's because the weight is
actually sitting there in the deadlift
it's because the weight is being the
force is being transferred through your
arms there but in either case you are
loading the axis of your spine
and that's fine if you know how to do it
safely but as you know you know having
done these things like that's not just
something you can walk in off the street
and do you really have to be coached how
to do that stuff safely and
you know stepping up onto a block is
something that's much safer to do
and it's also something that you can do
with a single leg at a time and
therefore you get to see what your
asymmetries are because we all have them
I mean I am so deep down the rabbit hole
of Step ups that I can't even like
explain the nuances in oblique
compression pelvic angles and the
difference between when my left and
right leg do it
but it you know tinkering with that
stuff allows me to work out so many
Kinks with with how my body works
you mentioned another one earlier which
is being able to carry heavy things
you know this is just such an essential
skill for our species it's something
that we do better than anything there is
no animal that can carry with their
hands what we can do
certainly a strong male but even a
strong female can carry their body
weight in their hands
you know half their body weight in each
hand is not it's not an insurmountable
ask for us would that be a hypothetical
Target for your patients
yeah we would like to see our patients
carry half their body weight in each
hand for a minute for a minute so walk
around with half your body weight any
chance for a minute yeah and having
strong hands is you know it's it's one
of the most correlated findings with
longevity so we talked earlier about
like what does it mean to be really
really strong well unfortunately the
data on this are based on what the
studies show and the studies are testing
you know interesting things but they're
not exhaustive right so they're usually
looking at grip strength leg extension
bench press are the most commonly tested
things
but grip strength comes up over and over
and over again in studies as such a
proxy for longevity
you know lower risk I think there's a
figure in in my book that talks about
The Unbelievable monotonic decline in
both the risk of onset of dementia and
death from dementia as grip strength
increases
again just kind of go back to the
Bradford Hill criteria and you look at
the strength of the associations you
look at the consistency of these
associations you look at the dose
effective these associations very hard
for me to believe that there isn't
causal relationships here and that being
stronger training to be stronger will
actually improve outcomes not just that
strength is a marker of Health which is
obviously correlated with living longer
if that makes sense yeah there's a
distinction there
so yeah we think that carrying things is
very important
yeah I'll go through different phases as
you know I love rocking so that's
another thing that I think is just a
great all-around way to kind of now
combine two different types of exercise
something that's part of strength and
something that's part of endurance is so
just for people who don't know rucking
is just basically carrying a really
heavy weighted backpack
probably one of the most important tools
used in the training of special forces
in the military I mean you know you we
have so many friends that have been
through that and
it's I'm amazed at how much they rocked
like it's yeah sort of like eight hours
a day they're just walking around with
75 pounds on their back if not more what
is your protocol methodology look like
for rucking
so I use 55 to 60 pounds and I'll
typically do an hour Ruck and because of
where I live it's really hilly so I
really like that going up the hills I'm
going hard you know I'm really pushing
my cardio up the hills and I'm trying to
find the steepest Hills possible to come
down because that's working that huge
eccentric gear it's really forcing me to
be able to decelerate on the way down
those Hills with a lot of weight and
you're not getting the pounding I mean I
think that's the beauty of it right is
you're not pounding your knee with the
impact you would if you had to run to
produce that effect